hey it's alex and today i'm going to
show you how to make my chocolate fudge
brownie cheesecake
so this was actually the first
cheesecake i ever did for tasty so i
guess you could say it was the
cheesecake that started it all
i really love cheesecake
so when i was developing this recipe
what i was really looking for was some
really beautiful layers
and
the flavor is pretty easy i mean what's
better than chocolate fudge brownie and
cheesecake so the bottom of this three
layer cheesecake is the brownie arguably
the best layer
i chose to make the brownie layer out of
box brownie mix but feel free to make
your own brownie recipe if you choose to
just makes it a little easier
so the second layer is the cheesecake of
course i chose to do a classic baked
cheesecake recipe so we're gonna have to
double bake this cheesecake because you
have to bake this cheesecake twice a lot
of people were worried that the brownie
layer would actually burn or get too
hard by the time the whole cheesecake is
done baking but don't worry the
cheesecake layer creates a sort of a
barrier and keeps your brownie really
fudgy and moist
and if you really wanted to you could
swap out the cheesecake layer for a
no-bake cheesecake and just pop it in
the fridge after your brownie is done
baking but i will always prefer a baked
cheesecake to a no-bake cheesecake so a
springform pan is really useful because
the sides release so it's great for like
a softer cake like a cheesecake when you
don't want to mess up the sides and
stuff so you just release am i
describing this well you just okay you
just open the clip on the side and lift
it up and you're ready to go in case
your cheesecake cracks a little bit on
the top don't worry we're gonna cover it
in our third layer which is the
beautiful chocolate ganache also very
delicious so chocolate ganache sounds
scary to make but it's super super easy
and it's delicious and very beautiful
all you have to do is melt down your
chocolate with hot heavy cream and mix
it until it creates a beautiful silky
mixture
once all the chocolate is melted you're
ready to go
this moment where i drizzled the
chocolate ganache over the cheesecake is
one of my proudest tasty moments
so the easiest way to do this glaze is
to move the cake onto a rack on a baking
sheet so when you pour over the
chocolate ganache it runs off into the
pan instead of all over your table
out of all of the videos i've made i
still go back to this shot because it's
so beautiful just the way the chocolate
drips over the cheesecake
[Music]
and if you want to since nothing should
go to waste you can take the rack off
and pour back any of the like residual
chocolate ganache into a bowl pop it in
the fridge eat it
later the chocolate ganache creates a
beautiful silky shiny layer on the
outside that will be sure to impress
anybody
you're trying to impress
this is a great date recipe i have to
say
very rich and indulgent
very sexy